mais quand ça commençait à rentrer il y
avait une vague cette vague est venue de
la mer à 10 km d'ici et là inondé le
ruisseau puis tout le terrain de Lucie
Lamoureux à waitly River près de
charlottante ça montait jusqu'à la porte
de la maison la force de l'eau a fait
éclater deux fenêtres du sous-sol qui
s’est ensuite rempli jusqu'au plafond
c'est les assurances et nous dit
peut-être décembre janvier il va être
capable de nous aider fait que mon mari
dit absolument pas son mari il travaille
pendant ses congés de fin de semaine
mais il y a encore beaucoup pas faire 30
jours plus tard c'est encore c'est
encore tout trempe et c'est la course
contre la montre avant l'arrivée du
temps froid pour isoler à nouveau le
sous-sol et installer deux nouvelles
fenêtres il y a pas assez de workers
pour faire les travaux
il manque de travailleurs parce qu'ils
sont déjà bien occupés à réparer les
maisons partout dans l'île à conwalk une
équipe espère terminer les travaux sur
celle-ci avant les fêtes bonsoir
il faut remplacer tous les barres d'eau
du toit nous explique Justin Summers une
entreprise
que la structure il a fallu arracher le
reste la plus a fait beaucoup de dégâts
il a une soixantaine de sinistrés sur sa
liste d'attentes
il aimerait embaucher d'autres
travailleurs il n'en trouvent pas les
dommages sont bien visibles d'un bout à
l'autre de la province des images
aériennes de la région de Rustico montre
les dommages près des côtes quatre
semaines après le passage de Fiona des
maisons sont toujours dans un état
lamentable
le grand ménage se poursuit dans la
capitale Charles
il y a encore de nombreux gros arbres à
couper et des maisons à libérer comme
celle de ce couple âgé qui regarde la
scène avec son petit-fils
c'est un soulagement on a continué à
vivre dans la maison on avait hâte que
l'arbre soit enlevé l'image de comment
que l'autre est venue Lucie peine à
croire ce qui lui arrive c'est deux
véhicules inondés eux aussi sont une
perte totale on est vraiment fatigué il
y a trop que ça se passe dans tête
il faudra encore beaucoup de patience
pour se remettre de Fiona ici Michel
Bridou Radio-Canada wither